sergey lavrov receives a rare warm
welcome on the international stage the
russian foreign minister came to india
after a visit to moscow's ally china
neither india nor china have condemned
russia's invasion of ukraine with india
abstaining from all votes on the war at
the united nations lavrov said russia
appreciates india's independent foreign
policy and along with china they're
working to bypass sanctions by using
different currencies many years ago we
started
moving
in our relations with india with china
and with many other countries from using
dollar
and euros to more and more use of
national currencies
under
this circumstances this trend i believe
will be intensified which is natural and
obvious
on the eve of lavrov's visit the indian
government defended its decision to
substantially increase oil imports from
russia
when oil prices go up i think it's
natural for countries to go out into the
market and look for what are good deals
for their people
but
i am pretty sure if we
wait two or three months and actually
look
at who are the big buyers of russian gas
and oil
i suspect the list won't be very
different from what it used to be
and i suspect we won't be in the top 10
on that list
say india is putting its own national
interests first like any other country
what i think is upsetting the western
nations
that
is the fact that the russians are
willing to
offer some oil to india
with a huge discount i'm told of almost
35
dollars so that of course
the western nations would like to equate
to profiteering but
i would imagine that
that is what any consumer would do when
they go to the supermarket if they find
there is a sale on something they want
to buy they will utilize it
russia is also india's biggest arms
supplier and lavrov said the war in
ukraine won't disrupt that
india is walking a thai trope as it
tries to keep good relations with russia
and the u.s
america's deputy national security
advisor for international economics the
leap singh visited indian officials
earlier this week the indian government
has so far withstood all pressure from
western nations to take a tougher stand
against russia the latest comments come
from the architect of u.s sanctions
against moscow who warned on his visit
to new delhi on thursday that there will
be consequences for countries who
circumvent them elizabeth peranam al
jazeera new delhi